the keynote speaker at Wednesday's mini
plenary session in Brussels the UN
sectional Ban ki-moon despite welcoming
Europe's new migration policy section
general reaffirmed his position against
use of force while we need to see a more
effective law enforcement protections
against the traffickers we also need
safe alternatives similar sentiments
were shared by some members of the House
the right to deal with migration and
refugees is not through military action
and I think that European institutions
are going in the wrong direction
Commission President jean-claude yonkers
plant 1021 billion euros of public funds
in 2015 13 years by luring private
investors took a step closer to reality
as the three stations finally shook
hands on the EU investment plan in the
early hours of Thursday morning could
the ease economic revival start here
tom has a parrot to a final vote with
the program set to be rolled out in the
summer some parliamentary committees
made their opinion clear in April they
weren't in favor of the private
arbitration mechanism under the
controversial trade investment
partnership or TTIP for the deal avoid
of the hangman's noose on Thursday of
the trade committee overwhelming Bacchus
recommendations to the Commission which
did not include deliberative high yes
the investor-state dispute mechanism
survey SDS confirm the privatization the
resistance would beat him on the no
Kosovo digimon division visita would be
in european the posting the ferry
professor
TTIP goes to a full plenary vote in June
at the Parliament vote down the trade
deal and finally get it say on IIST yes